just to make this very clear you didn't
want to come up here you're like I'm
throwing air
that's hope you don't
[Music]
dico this is wild morning guys
so today we're gonna go into the old
city of Lahore and I found a guy that
knows the secret areas of the old city
here and from all I've seen in the world
Lahore is old city is is one of the most
interesting let's get into this and have
a little adventure in this crazy
fascinating beautiful place Pakistan
[Music]
I don't our cell monied from yesterday I
don't do the master what are we gonna
get into today today we go to that never
feed we'll see the culture the hand ate
together soon is some secret areas yes
I'll show you yes the tobacco it's
tobacco actually used to be for the
fortune larger social gathering this is
actually the raw sugar tobacco and the
water
support feeds and what exactly people
like to delete it if that's all sir
that's for the and it's a brain the
court ring
you guys eat a lot yeah yeah so let me
show you that the stoop of Lahore
actually the streets are dead so Lahore
starts late right because all these
stores are closed right now exactly
actually a bit opens around 10 o'clock
or 11 okay it is goes two by eight it's
so quiet here
yes the cinema it's actually the
residency area Wow look at the narrow
street Wow
this is one of the oldest narrow street
in the whole this one yes
you know what was the reason of these
fates actually now because whenever
there was invaded attacking to the
Lahaul aha
so the people used to be these narrow
strips for escape and they could I think
it just outrun them yeah it's very cold
in here cool place guys this is so tight
this is basically basically my show that
is an actor angry you know what four
things most examples here if I'm a
minute away just one option left and
that is marriage believe I know you're
looking to get married and this is the
restroom that's the toilet because
because they have not enough space
forbid the restrooms from the winner
okay gas connections all the way uh-huh
facility of the people who are still
living yeah it's so cool in here I don't
know if the cameras catch capturing it
how it is but it's very it's widening a
little but it's a very very very tight
zone look at this door 200 years old it
was full with the knives for the seeker
because there was no cars over there
that's another gauge of Lahore
you know they didn't use any single
piece of Idol or anything it just plays
just a free clear and the lentil I'm not
seeing cement enough you can see the
symmetry of the break
Wow and that's changes here Wow
the most celebrated on Thursday this box
was filled in 1633 and billed by the
Shah Jahan Shah Jahan was a mughal
emperor or built apartment oh by the way
this is the signature of Shah Jahan he
built this before the Taj Mahal before
the parchment okay this is his signature
pattern of Shah Jahan so we are right
now in novels Elon Musk this is all the
Persian language the official language
of Lahore was a Persian mixer da and
this is the red sandstone its uranium
Jaipur the official languages Persian
Lahore yes there was no order make sure
the people of Lahore they can speak
Persian even though they can speak
Persian hanabishi my uterus chihaya too
much sauce man beautiful and I can speak
Pashto as well over there okay look at
the top it's actually the flower
and then we go inside you know what's
actually you can see the five arches
again it's covered with the cord this is
the one piece uh-huh
this is the second third fourth fifth
and the small that used to the music
although we're moogles actually they
were Mongolians they came from Central
Asia so they hire actually the architect
from all the way once they reach and
subcontinent here
but inside is a fresco this is fresco
Wow and you know about the fresco have
you been fifteen chapel I have not hello
hello did you feel like ooh sticks these
are the thing they were to build their
arts it was the reason behind this thing
that's why they built the arts is here
and this is curtain this is so this
disgusting it should be fixed here yeah
it's not good timing vegetal in here
five times train a day and the one
additional for the Friday prayer as well
how do people of Pakistan feel about the
British since they colonized
everywhere the rule right yeah but they
build a lot of things they gave us the
universe change the irrigation you know
the land report system their friend
strange the hospitals as well but they
do some better things as well right but
they do something wrong as well but you
have not lost your culture
Pakistan is we are laughing like you're
losing
yeah yes because people don't like to
speak their own language right they
don't use to berate the turban they
don't exist to bear laughter this across
and if the mordrem
actually in the home if we speak the
Punjabi is our pub neck where it's
people considered that you are not
educated so what are you speaking
English Oh heard is the more educated
exactly but all people still and you can
see through the lost time here oh yeah
the whole locks here he's in charge of
the law exactly so I gotta say I was
here my first day here these streets
were insane chaos okay and now it's very
peaceful
yeah definitely it's quite nice because
the shops would often actually around a
12 o'clock yeah this is actually
traditional style of like it's not a
break farmer I think but it's like are
we call in a typical language just car I
think it tastes really good yes sir
right yeah we're soon
the change this time
anything
[Music]
feel like I'm throwing error
Mentos with the lentils and there are
two type of lentils and then they're
they're boiled in this modern era as
well wow it's so difficult to be
disorganized Oh looks pretty comfortable
- yeah it's very comfortable and it's
very difficult to be here four to five
in a day they can complete Wow okay he's
got is his feet holding one of the ropes
exactly 50 years Wow if doing this one I
think oh this is very disgusting thing
that his son is not doing this work so
maybe this is the last generation
otherwise they're gonna stop so the
culture actually is going dying this
faith yes your fastest here very active
because the answer because reads they're
actually because we eat 350 years in
same profession right that's why look at
the tree he's a true master Wow
it's same here as though we can cheat a
barber okay
giver the old barbers oh yeah
she kept the barber to charge only like
on a 20 or 30 cents on 30 years to the
same place and same profession is doing
that air that's the haunted tree
it's proximately 600 years old haunted
tree pakistanis I guess it depends what
region what people you're talking about
but there are they very superstitious
yes they are they are even that if a
black cat calls to your way yeah but the
thing about is something is bad playing
off in today
but this is actually one of the oldest
one I remember in my childhood I used to
be playing with this Rob sexily swing
with the road
yeah now what one of the most famous
saying but Lahore the person who didn't
see in the not born yet
so Peter you were born right now I was
just born because people Janell Lord
it's a KO jhemini person it didn't seal
the heart north born yet so okay i
marriage is fine but marriage actually
would consider here only the one lady
Islam allows for for ladies but mostly
people have done the one ladies it's
enough it's enough for the one as well
yeah I think I mean managing one I have
a great relationship prof. Eck's
it's fine if you a girlfriend right but
I'm just saying I couldn't imagine
managing like being I have more people I
have done I have my good friends right
over here we considered the girlfriend
is entirely different
right yeah it's definitely you have to
be like intercourse with the girlfriend
is
right right right okay but my point is
being with one person there's a lot to
it you know I couldn't imagine being
with four yeah would be an insane life
exactly definitely oh god you'd be
balanced in exact management okay I told
you would adored okay so tell me some
other interesting things about Pakistani
culture okay the trial gender was very
German and like 200 years back in
subcontinent the transgenders
we called the eunuchs actually eunuch
yes yes eunuchs okay when you say
transgenders are accepted here right now
be receptive right now yes you're a
separate interesting maybe that's Paris
so now I then defrayed here and then the
fries here actually the capture they
called the world uh-huh it's illegal
as per the law gotcha a madman
to walk the water pumping station yeah
exactly so the water supply to all the
walls in the actually okay let's go in
oh these are massive tanks up here
exactly this is actually the beauty of
this city it was a cosmopolitan city the
Muslims can live here freely the Hindus
the Jews the Christians and other
religions as well
even at the Parsee in Iran there are a
lot of solutions right so we have the
solution graveyards in law all we have
we have the service
what's cosmopolitan it falls it not
right now it's not know at all what is
this this is not like opium opium and
Ashish as well so it's a used to be by
the winter it's very expensive yeah it's
very expensive to the polish to get it
this thing
so this that's opium disappearing yes
and so they smoke it on the smoker there
are many problems actually
but we knows when they give Brian McCann
they all live together they give it a
nice little high regard
is it happy be dead everything is sad we
already happy to see you guys there
thank you okay so tell me about the
opium actually during the Russian war
although actually the Afghan is right
they they migrated from Afghanistan to
Pakistan here right so our plan is was
the only one who are ready to fight
against erection and Oksana become a new
spotter right so majority of the ganas
migrated from Kingston to Pakistan today
and on that time the army personnel
allow actually to the heart to do the
valleys that they can do the business so
they don't have any King on their time
put yourself off here all the way to
everyone so that's why it's now very
kumuk business in Pakistan so a lot of
people are no yes it's not a very strong
it's very strong it slopes because it's
just like a second stage addiction right
and the later on you can see this guys
for the defense he was very young
definitely yeah he used to know
injections as well if you want to be
killed any family
to get them to offer him to anyone first
of all the family was done
the last generation in Lahore they are
doing this thing here making the job
making the drums and they are very
famous in the city you can see the to
note it whenever I can Enclave future
chipiya each other you know Sofia I know
she Allah okay okay
all all people doing this thing by hand
new generation don't like to think
starting to get a little more life here
yes life is woke up everywhere people on
the streets is making tea
[Music]
making all the way
Salam alaikum they all make you fight
your hands even that they have the
harmonium they are making by the hands
so that he's making all these
instruments yes Wow even the Mafia
it's a very beautiful and maybe it's
gonna be perform as well he's gonna
perform
you
[Music]
[Applause]
the master you finish for you
[Music]
now figures in the ERR subsidy you see
the break way down there and yeah
that's the city absolutely just a bridge
today yeah yeah and they have two
different kind of the shoeboxes they can
make me 1,500 boxes they can make it in
daily this is selling one of the older
already found in the hoarder like it's
250 years rent and here's the it's only
the last one if he died nobody can yeah
he's the last one making the style this
is the typical bread after the yeast its
yeast and only the specific people can
eat it no any anyway even though you
click on it it already has been dead
before they can make right why can't I
eat it what can you eat it yeah because
it's approximately one day old jeez make
one day old
typical voice the rich person from here
they had the stairs it's indicated the
Royal actually the the noble person
maybe we're respectable person the lives
in service but I realize they have the
steep stairs yes she's a Hindu please
don't work
but the that matters like this so
is there like a leader let's say in this
community
everyone is community this is the old
lady and everything just gonna be even
had these guys lighten up he did it up
the Shelf because all people like to eat
that's culture go to narrow street he
knows the home the old people who like
this sort of thing so he's a legend here
no one to do this to do this one this is
the last one look at the draining system
of Lahore the tower is underground train
yeah you could see so quite yeah it's
nice becquer
okay in the summers is it cool it
winters got a one summer it's cold
okay so what did you go back and replace
please we go to this trip you go again
we can your package it so maybe someone
sit over there maybe someone sits about
the places this is cool this is cool
right this is again people consider
maybe this tree is haunted again you get
the wrestlers with the Saints here
anything
so the people actually love to be like
in this feature this is the constituency
of Nawaz Sharif he's done a lot of work
of what this is the law and it is fine
you know the colorful art of color in
here again here this tartan Islam you
couldn't make it long he owned a little
icon in his LOM right right like 1400
years back but now everything is gonna
change so it really depends where you
are in what Muslim country and where you
are if this is okay or not okay
I could get one thing yeah we have you
have what we had the mobile yeah we have
the ID card as well we had to face
choristers hello
he's eating pawn early morning is the
breakfast without without this thing is
effectively it's a bit early and so they
they love to eat it
things here it's a ritual here so in
Islam definitely do not allow to the
face icon but now everything has changed
looks like a UNIX it's like the feelings
of the UNIX you know the other stuff
which are more saturation up ticket see
Kashyap yeah thank you you could go this
route okay we need to go back here we go
a little further
sure why not this is interesting look at
the sparrows again you call him she yes
we won he you can decide oh because he's
got so little feminine what is what does
that mean Hindu religion right yeah and
Islam Islam don't teach us like this
thing right look at this beautiful
harmony
[Music]
[Applause]
he was hinder it was Muslim but we live
with the Hindu since ages yeah yeah so
we got the rituals from Indians it's
interesting the real the real code we
haven't seen the real culture of GRU add
the real culture of the holiday look at
the yoga make with the white beard I had
that you know people here your culture
are very friendly and yeah yeah not
camera-shy yeah yeah because they always
welcome to the tourists always that but
they're they're fine with the camera you
know very surprised to see the
parliamentary guys mostly this is the
place the bill no any corners go there
they don't come here they're not come
here did her head in trust here
why not this is the interesting part
this is the culture but they say I don't
have time we do we need to visit the
moss we need to visit the lava for you
to be these places I like yeah yeah yeah
this is the real table okay that is the
fresh vegetable Wow and it's very very
cheap here and mostly all the people
actually buddy this is very expensive
property you're saying like the
apartment up here is very small the
building is but you're gonna get the
door yeah it's approximately I'm sure
the cost of the stories are all of my
comm called in to your store the
thousand dollars
how old is how old this is store Wow you
know all the way expensive so how much
do you think like this guy above okay
Salam alaikum is the local residents may
be some how much is how much is his
apartment where up how on this dollar
thirty five thousand euros dollars
approximately that
yeah that's that's about as fresh as it
comes it goes from there no no yes from
here you could have death thank you for
the blood air and then go there go to
the top and then they beat and then they
cut it and there it goes to that guy
they supplied to the market Wow
all right you'll get a donkey
what's he burning here it's just like
for the hot water take out the water
heater yeah okay look it's going check
this guys
[Music]
the trash unfortunately I had part of a
donkey donkeys for the freaks at
everything
Hotel luxury is a brick plaster really
the picture right now you can see here
he works too much
one of the ordered coffee market
vegetable markets because they carry the
constant and all the this is judicial
oil shop in Lahore okay and this is this
guy's a modren is a modern guy he's
educated there used to be the old
cultural style here
see here he's are making oil push the
oil actually it's the literal and you
know him the Ox have actually discovered
in the ice rocks don't know what's going
on the odd
wait so the ox is blinded in doing
circles all day long so he walks all day
to search this guy walks all day and see
with the arm he's checking that Chili's
and maybe thought boy he's gonna pull ok
low-five low-five
no pike oh she's fast she's really fast
oh-oh
so we're seeing auxes turned oil yeah
we're seeing all this old world life
yeah but in Lahore yeah there are mega
shopping models yeah luxury car
yeah right all these things existing at
the same time right yeah I just want to
make sure that here knows the whole city
is not this yeah it's a city of 12
million people and there's everything
yeah and but this is the stuff that's
interesting I don't know this is what is
this a sucky this is the school but
there are very different thing I
remember in my childhood this is a fine
the people dispose pressure the children
they can easily get it that the guys
here now so it's like the ice cream
truck
do you ever see you get excited that's
why I'm good on cotton candy I had
enough when I was a kid
okay so sterile buckets and look at the
beautiful Kavita here this is a
beautiful square you you called the
square huh what is it huh
oh really a burly actually the whole
area was caused in a local language by
you Mohammad on high actually it means
the dancing area see the design of that
look to the arch the demons yes
these are the demons you get the faces
with the - hell yeah yeah they have
planned to distort this theory actually
or to your story they are working so
they are for the Department of the
government department they are planning
and how people living over there how
they can change their lifestyle so if we
take them trapeze architects okay of all
so your your plans are to restore many
of these neighborhoods that's a lot of
work there's so much in here so a
feeling I get in the heart is so full
and then chaos yes but it feels sick it
doesn't feel like dangerous chaos is not
everywhere make sure right chaos is
everywhere into the world then different
right chaos so I mean is all the
activity not like it's not a bad thank
you I wasn't thinking about the back no
no no chaos feeling like whoa yes
colours lights smells everything we have
so yeah it's it's a to balance like I've
never seen anywhere in the world you
know don't get a little sweater
it's nice fashion huh yeah it is
these donkeys are building the old city
huh yeah it's the old one actually
though the three first
places a playground
who knows everybody salamualikum' thank
you for that that was a cool thank you
look into the inner guts of this senator
I hope so I dr. d'hubert very well you
are off you thank you
you are the real tourists then enjoy
their everything and see everything this
is the cool stuff I don't want to go to
some shopping mall and that's the thing
is here you know exactly unique in the
city everybody to the ward you go if you
don't go to the downtown yeah thank you
so guys hope you like that you're a true
champion thank you
I'm gonna leave a link if you ever want
to tour the city this is the man thank
you
and corner tomorrow off no tonight off
to Islamabad and then up to the mountain
tons of valley some of the most
beautiful mountains in the world okay
thanks for coming along like and
subscribe if you want to support this
channel hit the notification bell to be
the first to see my next video many more
videos about hackus tan and other parts
of the world coming soon